okay so the next question is when
does the judgment of the wicked
take place the judgment of the wicked
occurs during the thousand years
the investigative judgment as the bible scholars
prefer to call it the pre-advent judgment is a
judgment going on right now because when christ
comes the righteous will come from their graves
immortal in order to come from the grave
immortal once you come from the grave immortal
there's no need for a judgment for you someone
has already decided that's how you'll come up
first corinthians 15 51-55 the dead shall be
raised incorruptible they can no longer die
they come up with immortality well who decided
that it had to be decided before they were raised
and so there is a judgment going on now it is
the judgment on those who claim to have been a
part of the house of god first peter chapter 4 17
for the time is come the judgment must begin at
the house of god the house of god means those who
have professed some sort of relationship with god
the house of god has wheat and tares but they
are the house of god and the judgment is to
decide who is the we and who is the tear when
that is finished that's when jesus comes back
and when we get to heaven with him then we begin
the judgment of the wicked now let me be clear
the judgment of the wicked is different from the
judgment of the just the judgment of the just or
the house of god is to decide who was really
faithful who was not then decisions are made
as to who will be saved who will not the judgement
of the wicked is not to decide who would be saved
the fact that they did not come up in the first
resurrection is all the proof we need that they
are already lost the judgment is for the redeemed
and for angels and the unfallen worlds to see
that god's judgment against the wicked was
just that throughout eternity or since the
controversy began god has always been just because
eloise tells us it was only when some angels saw
what satan did to christ on the cross that they
finally cut off all sympathy with him up to
that point some angels still believe he had been
unfairly treated if you read first peter chapter
1 verse 12 it tells us at the end of verse 12
which things the angels desire to look into angels
do not understand everything and since we're
heading for a world where sin will never return
everyone has to be absolutely convinced that
sin is a bad thing and righteousness is the way
to live and so it takes a thousand years for
us the unfallen worlds and the angels to see
that god is just that is why before the wicked
destroy after the thousand years before satan
is destroyed every lost person will bend the knee
and say that jesus christ is lord they will agree
that god was right in his judgment and then
they'll be destroyed and so the judgment of
the wicked is not to decide who will be lost
that's already decided by their own choice the
judgment of the wicked is for the redeemed to sit
with christ and examine the records and to see
that the punishment they're about to receive
is just now let me say something else there's
a difference between punishment and wages but
they're all connected the wages of sin is death
but according to luke 12 42-48 some are beaten
with many stripes some are beaten with few stripes
the more wicked you are the more you suffer
before you die now this is not the sort of
thing people want to hear they want to hear
how to get rich how to get a husband or wife
but the bible has many many things we need to
be familiar with even the most familiar first
in the bible has death and life for god so loved
the world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should not
perish what does perish mean burn in the fires
of hell but have everlasting life a life with
god and so in that thousand years we will see
that various periods of suffering will be assigned
to different people and we know that satan will
burn the longest before he finally perishes
he burns the longest clearly because he said
some people the moment the fires hit them they
consumed because their lives were not that wicked
so we have differences in suffering before the
final blotting out but all will finally die
because the wages of sin is death and so the bible
says behold i come quickly and my reward is with
me to give every man according as his word shall
be if you've been very very wicked you suffer
more before you die remember suffering is attached
both to salvation and to damnation because jesus
suffered and the loss will suffer similarly sorry
for that oh there's no problem this is what we're
here for um but i thank you for that explanation
really i did not know before i read um the truth
about angels by ellen i didn't know that the
angels you know sympathize with satan i was like
and really white also said that we're
living this life for self-revelation
so god doesn't know who's not going to die or and
who's not going to go to hell but he's doing it so
we can see with our own eyes why made a certain
choice um and yes definitely the wicked will be
destroyed and the righteous will help um jesus
judge yeah so the last question that i have is
based on revelation 21 verse 2 we know that new
jerusalem descends from heaven to earth after
the millennium but in the earth when hell fire
comes down yes it is it comes down on mount of
olives the mountain splits a part of that earth
is made holy and sacred that's where the city sits
when the earth is consumed with fire revelation 20
verse 9 and 10 the fires burn all around the city
and loi tells us while the fires are burning the
save that's us will be in the city safe and secure
uh great controversy page 673 paragraph three the
redeemed will be in the earth in the in the city
watching this global conflagration they
will be safe from the fire the wicked
will be consumed and it'll take several days
for the fire to finally do its work because
it burns up the earth physically it burns up
the atmosphere it burns up the spirit beings
and it is a flames of burning differently you know
there's some i wonder if i should tell you this is
so it's so frightening but ly says as long as a
little part of you is left that is not consumed
you feel all the agony of the burning so if
the only thing left to burn is a fingernail
you feel it as though all of you is still burning
it's hell is no place to be that's why she says we
have a heaven to gain and a hell to shaman let
me say people do not like to hear these things
they find them depressing but then there's
something called negative motivation
negative motivation means i don't want to go
to hell and there's nothing wrong with that
and we have negative negative motivation in john
3 16 whosoever believeth in him should not perish
and so i have a reason to be saved i want to be
with jesus but i also do not want to go to hell
my major reason is jesus but i don't want to
go to hell and so eloise said we have a heaven
to gain and the hell to shine actively you
must actively shun hell shunning hell does
not happen automatically you must actively
shun hell and everything that is hellish
thank you for that we do not want to be in hell
guys no no you don't let's do what we have to
do now and just before i go me and my mother we
were talking about the judgment and i literally
told her that jesus is the shield the difference
between the rit the righteous and the wicked is
literally jesus so the wicked just rejected their
shield from god's wrath that's right that's right
but guys there's nothing we can do jesus
did everything thank you of the randy skeet
it was a pleasure questioning you i
will turn it back to denisha all right
you